let's have Melanie Mitchell give our
final opening statement six minutes on
the clock Melanie yeah so this is this
is my opportunity to say I love Melanie
she is amazing and and she's coming back
on mlst
in about two weeks oh amazing yes that's
good actually gives a good
representation of herself in in here I
think Melanie is amazing
it's about machines on unleashing human
extinction have deep roots in our
Collective psyche these fears are as old
as the invention of machines themselves
but tonight we're debating whether these
fears belong in the realm of Science
Fiction and philosophical speculation or
whether AI is an actual real life
existential threat
I'm going to argue that AI does not pose
such a threat in any reasonably near
future
large language models have sparked
heated debate on whether ai's exhibit
genuine understanding of language and
the world
with capabilities rivaling humans across
diverse benchmarks some hail language
models as harbingers of real
intelligence but Skeptics argue that
their Mastery is Skin Deep lacking true
comprehension
so how can we assess these claims and
gain insight into the nature of what it
means to understand
now on the show today we have Professor
Melanie Mitchell a leading thinker on AI
and intelligence and one of the
researchers in the community I
personally most align with and look up
to the most
Melanie's distinguished career crosses
computer science complex systems and
cognitive science and she wrote the
influential books artificial
intelligence a guide for thinking humans
and also complexity a guided tour
now Central to Melanie's perspective is
the idea that human understanding relies
on flexible mental models grounded in
sensory experience now she wrote that
understanding language requires having
the concepts that language describes yet
large language models are trained purely
on statistical relationships between
words their knowledge is not grounded in
a causal model of reality
now Melanie is the Davis professor of
complexity at the Santa Fe Institute and
her major work has been in the areas of
analogical reasoning complex systems
genetic algorithms and cellular automata
she's achieved legendary status in the
field of AI she received her PhD in 1990
from the University of Michigan under
Douglas hofstadter the famous author of
godor escherbach Melanie argues that we
must rethink how AI systems are
evaluated typical benchmarks summarize
aggregate performance and you know these
obscure failure modes and mask the
underlying mechanisms we need rigorous
granular testing focused keenly on
abstract generalization sort of like a
Sorcerer's Apprentice gone nuclear
for example yahshua bengio wrote about
this thought experiment we might ask an
AI to fix climate change and to solve a
problem it could design a virus that
decimates the human population
Presto humans dead no more carbon
emissions
this is an example of what's called the
fallacy of dumb super intelligence
that is it's a fallacy to think that a
machine could be quote smarter than
humans in all respects unquote and still
lack any Common Sense understanding of
humans such as understanding why we made
the request to fix climate change and
the fact that we'd prefer not to be
wiped out
intelligence is all about having insight
into one's goals and the likely effect
of one's actions beautiful we would
never give unchecked autonomy and
resources to an AI that lacked these
basic aspects of intelligence it just
does not make sense
the third scenario yeah that is
absolutely she made that point so much
more eloquently than I've tried to make
it in in the past yeah I think yeah I
mean even early in this conversation I
was trying to try to get that across but
that's exactly it it's this dumb super
intelligence you know yeah exactly
anyway folks I hope you enjoy the show
and now I bring you Professor Melanie
Mitchell sounds like almost like there's
a very quiet super computer running
behind the uh you know that's great it's
my brain yeah
you know we can robustly
um you know adapt much more so than gpt4
yeah you and I have the same share we
have the same chair right now yeah I
can't see your chair yeah
yeah I think they're all the same chair
yeah yeah this is an excellent chair yep
cheer buddies yeah I felt it would be
hundreds of years before anything even
remotely
like a human mind would be
asymptotically approaching the level of
the human mind but from beneath
I never imagined that computers would
rival or let alone surpass human
intelligence but it seemed to me like it
was a goal that was so far away I wasn't
worried about it but when certain
systems started appearing and then this
started happening at an accelerating
Pace it felt as if not only are my
belief systems collapsing but it feels
as if the entire human
race is going to be eclipsed and left in
the dust
um Douglas hofstetter
he he came out as a Doomer
well
I don't know if he came out exactly he's
been a Doomer for quite a while
oh go on I wasn't aware of that well I
don't you know Doomer is you know
there's different kinds of doomers so in
my AI book the first chapter or the
first the prologue is called terrified
and it's all about how Doug is very
terrified about Ai and the possible
things that are going to come and
um that was
based on a talk he gave in 2013
and earlier than that he was extremely
worried about the singularity the idea
of the singularity from Kurzweil and
wrote quite a bit about that so I I feel
like that that it's not that new
thing but maybe this is sort of because
there's so much talk about AI doom and
so on that this is kind of uh people are
kind of paying attention now
yeah I don't know whether I
misunderstood something because I read
out you had this beautiful piece about
the Googleplex and Shopper yeah he was
he was terrified that um cognition might
be disappointingly simple to mechanize
and you know surely we could replicate
the influence the you know the infinite
Nuance of of the the mental state that
went into writing that beautiful music
but so maybe he was worried about it but
he didn't think it was possible in
principle or something
well no he was quite worried about that
it was going to happen sooner than he
thought and that you know his quote that
it's AI is going to leave us in the dust
right so that's kind of his flavor of
Doomer I'm not sure he
has the same like you know existential
worry about things as like Stuart
Russell or somebody
okay
so have you not so worried about them
necessarily uh churning us into you know
fertilizer or raw materials or something
but just yeah it's not so specific I
think
but yeah yeah I talked to him about it
all the time and
um he wavers
oh interesting because I'm I've heard
you define yourself as a Centrist on on
other podcasts because I'm sure I'm sure
the doomers would would uh lump you in
with with Chalet and and and and lacoon
maybe in some of the some of the critics
but but um you do think that these
models are intelligent right
I do think that they're intelligent well
you know intelligence is a
ill-defined notion oh yes
multi-dimensional and um you know I I
don't know if we can say yes or no about
something being intelligent rather than
you know intelligent in certain ways or
in to certain degrees
yeah well we've got so much to to get
into I mean I think slowly we'll talk
about arkhan and your concept Arc work
but I I um kind of agree with you that
and actually you had that paper out
about the four fallacies and and you
spoke about this fallacy of her pure
intelligence and I kind of agree that
the gnarly reality is is far more
complex than that there was a really
interesting paper that you linked on no
it was an article by dilip George and he
said that a university Professor has a
much better understanding of a vector
because it's just grounded in so many
real world situations and contexts and
so on and an undergraduate or indeed a
language model would have a very
ungrounded very kind of low resolution
idea of what this concept is and it kind
of leans away from this puritanical
ungrounded abstract form of intelligence
to something which is really very
complex and intermingled
yeah I mean I agree with that
well except that but there's two there
are another aspect to that too which you
write about which is
I I agree that that happens but what the
human mind also seems to do is as a
thing becomes more grounded in in more
cases then we develop yet another
concept that kind of describes the you
know similar the similar aspects that we
see throughout all those different
concepts right so we're we're kind of
this iterative Loop where we're always
finding more and more context and then
we're also finding newer and newer
Concepts that span those increasing
contexts is that fair yeah sure yeah
I mean that that kind of goes along with
it
all sort of um
for theory of cognition of Lake office
at all and that you know we're sort of
building on these physical metaphors
that we can build up many many layers of
abstraction
um
so yeah we can talk about that
we're not recording yet right
oh no we are we are this is a recording
oh we are I hope you're okay with what
you've said what you said so far but
yeah so there's there's the lack of
building on
um you know the the body of of symbols
as pointers and by the way that delete
George article was really fascinating
because it was saying that language is a
conditioning Force so actually we all
have these high resolution World
simulators built into us and we kind of
like condition how that operates and
generate counterfactuals through
language which I thought was quite
interesting yeah
yeah um why don't you frame up uh frame
up the debate because we we found a
beautiful we did we did we found a paper
the amazing
but just just a closer loop on what I
was saying we were discussing inactivism
last night I'm not sure if you're
familiar with some of these externalized
forms of of cognition than we were
talking about the concept of a goal and
agents of course they just have these
high-resolution belief trajectories of
you know I can do all of these different
actions and that's not really a goal you
know a goal is this very abstract thing
which emerges at the at the system level
and no individual agents in the system
have a concept of a goal and it might be
similar with with some of these Concepts
that we're talking about which is to
what extent do they exist and to what
extent are they just something
intelligible that we can point to but
they don't really meaningfully exist in
the system at a high resolution
are you talking about in AI or in people
like little
pieces
I think goal is a wonderful example
because we think of it I mean it's even
one of um spellkey's core priors it
seems like something so primitive
um but I don't think they really do
exist in in US I mean we're interesting
because we have this reflexive
conception of a goal that does a mouse
have a goal
right I mean
goal is another one of those words that
you know we use in a very fluid way so
we talk about for instance a
reinforcement learning agent having a
goal that we've given to it right or it
might have a goal to to to kind of
maximize its Information Gain or
something
um but is that the same thing as a human
having a goal uh that that this is it's
like you know too too to graduate from
college or to you know uh do make
something of your life or all of these
things they're very it's a very
different sense of goal and so I would
say yes a mouse has goals uh but those
goals are
different in degree and in kind of
qualitatively than many of the things we
call goals in humans and in machines so
I think goal is one of those sort of
anthropomable morphizing words
that we need to be careful about when we
if we if we if we equate goals in these
different systems as being the same
thing and I actually you know had a
discussion with I think it was with
Stuart Russell
um about the notion of goal and his View
and I think this is a view of other
people many other people in AI is that
large language models actually have
goals complex goals that they
um
that are emerge out of this
you know their loss function of
predicting the next token
because the only way to successfully
protect predict the next token in in
human language is to develop human-like
goals I find that dubious
but it's an interesting perspective
yeah I'm amenable to it um because
there's always this dichotomy as you say
of there's there's the objective there's
perplexity and there's these emergent
goals and there's even this simulators
theory of large language models which is
that they're a superposition of of
agents and it's quite situated as well
because goals kind of materialize
depending on your perspective so if you
use a language model in a certain way
from a certain perspective it might
appear that there is some kind of goal
there but of course you're it's just an
aspect onto something which is very
complex but I I think we should frame up
this beautiful piece actually from your
um modes of understanding paper from
March this year I always call it the
modes of understanding paper it was
actually titled the debate over
understanding an ai's large language
models and um you said towards the end
of the the key question of the debate
about understanding in in large language
models is one is talking of
understanding in such systems simply a
category error which is mistaking
associations between language tokens for
associations between tokens and physical
social and mental experience in short is
it the case that these models are not
and will never be the kind of things
that can understand or conversely two do
these systems or their near-term
successes actually even in the absence
of physical experience create something
like the rich concept based mental
models that are Central to human
understanding and if so does scaling
these models create even better Concepts
or three if these systems do not create
such Concepts can their unimaginably
large systems of statistical
correlations produce abilities that are
fundamentally equivalent to human
understanding or indeed that enable new
forms of higher order logic that humans
are incapable of accessing and at this
point will it still make sense to call
such correlations spurious and there are
the resulting Solutions shortcuts and
would it make sense to see these systems
behaviors not as competence without
comprehension but as a new non-human
form of understanding and you said that
these questions are no longer in the
realm of abstract philosophical
discussions but they touch on very real
concerns about the capabilities and
robustness and safety and ethics of AI
systems so so let's use that as a leader
what do you think Melanie it's beautiful
that there's a beautiful paragraph by
the way yeah wow this is exactly
crystallizes the discussion
um yeah I think that it it's it's
something that you know we and AI are
all grappling with now and I think it's
something that you know the history of
uh if AI has has forced us to Grapple
with mental terms like understand or
um Consciousness and and even
intelligence because we keep you know
say saying oh well you know
understanding if if you can do X then
that means that you're actually
understanding you know you can't
you can't uh do
language translation without
understanding you can't do speech to
text without understanding you can't
generate articulate uh
natural language without understanding
and I think this is the in in many cases
we we will then step back and say wait
that's not what we meant by
understanding it turns out you can do
all these things without understanding
so we're sort of saying well we didn't
really know what we meant by the term
understanding I think and you know often
some people criticize that as moving the
goal posts
you know you're moving AI effect right
right it's the AI effect but I think of
it more as AI is
is forcing
uh
people to really refine their Notions
of that that have been quite fuzzy about
what these terms actually make
and there was there was a fantastic
um Talk by uh Dave Chalmers the
philosopher who I think you've probably
had on this this show uh
that where he he talks about conceptual
engineering which is something that
philosophers do where they take a term
like understanding and they they refine
it and he he said okay well we have you
know P understanding which is like you
know personal
phenomenological and then we have
see understanding and E understanding
and X understanding and all these
different letters that meant to say that
this term is not like a unified thing
that we can apply to to a system we have
to really specify what we mean exactly
well one way I've come to think about it
and it's largely from from reading your
your work and your assessments about it
is that for the first time we're
actually being forced to do
the science of machine cognition right
because because for too long it's either
just not been sophisticated enough you
know why bother like it's obviously not
not doing any cognition and as you point
out it's now actually having real world
you know impacts and so we actually have
to start doing the science right we have
to say Okay does this thing have
cognition here's a hypothesis let's do
some tests okay it failed what was the
failure mode why did it fail let's
understand that more how can we engineer
it not to fail it's like we can no
longer ignore adversarial examples
shortcut learning Etc we have to finally
grapple with it it seems to me
yeah I think that's exactly right and
and what's interesting is we computer
scientists were never trained in
experimental methods
we never learned about like controls and
and and and you know confounding it's a
great thing uh and
so now people are doing
you know applying human tests of
understanding or intelligence or
reasoning what have you to machines
without having the right experimental
methods to to say whether or not what
they're testing is actually you know
valid so there's a cognitive scientist
named Michael Frank at Stanford who's
been writing a lot of stuff about
experimental method and how do you apply
it to Ai and why you need
sort of expertise in this area
to really make sense of these systems
and I I'm totally on board with that
yeah we'll talk about your piece we have
Tannenbaum later but as you say a lot of
AI folks don't really think about
experiment design but actually even with
chalet's Arc challenge maybe we should
talk about that so he he invented this
measure of intelligence which
unfortunately was not computable but it
was you know
um mathematically beautiful
um but basically saying that and he's a
huge spoky fan I kind of um put surely
very very close to you actually in in AI
researcher space and um his measure of
intelligence basically says um I I give
you priors I give you experience you
give me a skill program it extrapolates
into these different spaces and
experience space and the the kind of the
the conversion ratio between those
priors and experience and and the space
that I get is intelligence and um that's
very interesting and then he produced
this Corpus this Arc Challenge and it's
a bit like an IQ test it's this kind of
um uh 2D gridded colored cells and you'd
have a couple of examples and you have
to do another one or two examples and it
was is very diverse because it was
testing what he called developer aware
generalization and there were a couple
of issues with that so you you wrote
this beautiful
um concept Arc paper and maybe you can
introduce that but one of the things you
pointed out which I thought was quite
interesting is that even if people
succeeded on Francois challenge it
wouldn't necessarily be what we would
call intelligence because it's not
necessarily demonstrating systematic
generalization Beyond those one or two
examples in his test set
so our motivation was twofold
um so first of all I love the arc
challenge it's beautiful it's it's
you know super elegant and I'm very
sympathetic with um
Francois uh definition of intelligence
although I think there's probably again
intelligence is very multi-dimensional
but you know this is one aspect of it
for sure and
his problems are great because you know
they they just give a few examples and
people are pretty good at abstracting a
rule or a concept from just a few
examples
and they don't use language
so they don't get into the whole like
prior knowledge of language and and uh
a lot of things that that you don't want
to confound these tests but one of the
problems with Arc is that the prop so
many of the problems are quite hard
they're quite hard for people
and they're so hard that
They Don't Really differentiate between
different programs that are attempting
to solve this challenge so there was a
kaggle competition with The Arc
Challenge and there were two the two
best programs got about they each got
about 20 percent
accuracy on the hidden test set
um so it didn't really distinguish them
at all
um
and the other problem was that
as as you mentioned the test wasn't very
systematic meaning that let's say
there's a problem in Arc that deals with
the concept of in inside something being
inside something else and let's say that
something a program gets that one right
does that mean that it understands the
concept of inside in a general way well
we don't know because the test doesn't
test that systematically
um and that was actually intentional
from Chalet because he didn't want any
way to for programs to be able to like
reverse engineer
the the the the generation process of
these program of these problems so if
you say oh well I'm going to deal with
these like 10 Concepts
then somebody presumably could reverse
engineer those the problems and not be
General but for us we wanted to say well
how would you systematically test a
program for understanding of a concept
of a very basic spatial or semantic
concept
and so what we did was we took the arc
domain and we created about
um almost 500 new problems that were
systematically grouped into
concept groups so like inside of that
was one of the groups and um
so we looked at we created several
problems that were variations on that
concept and there were variations that
um ranged in like abstraction degree of
abstraction and a sort of complexity of
the problem and
the the hypothesis was that if if a
human or a program could successfully uh
solve the problems in a given concept
group they really have do have a good
sort of grasp of that concept
so this was the Genesis of concept Arc
you know it's fascinating because so
you're you're attempting again to build
the science of of machine cognitive
science essentially and hey it has to be
systematized we need to have these
concept categories we need to be able to
generate examples of progressive
complexity and you know layer of
abstraction and everything and then yet
you mentioned Chalet intentionally
didn't systematize it to avoid reverse
engineering and that's kind of a
fascinating point because reverse
engineering can even happen you know
just by way of selection bias so I mean
researchers are out there they're
fooling around with different neural
network structures maybe I'll add like a
u here or some horseshoe over there and
lo and behold suddenly it works really
well on the concept of inside out and
I'm going to claim this is machine
learning even though it was actually
human engineering that sort of put that
structure into the network so in the in
the long term you know how do we how do
we balance that or how do we avoid it or
how do we test for machine induced you
know prior knowledge versus actual
machine learning
or human years no I understand it's a
it's a hard problem and I think you know
the goal with this concept are uh
Benchmark wasn't to sort of supplant Arc
in any way it was really meant to be
complementary and it was meant to be
kind of a stepping stone
to the much larger and more difficult
Arc set because I think you know even if
I tell you all of these problems have to
do with the concept of inside versus
outside
you would still have to have a good
grasp of those Concepts in order to
solve these problems
and I'm not sure that you could sort of
engineer something
um that would solve those cons problems
of that Concept in general
without having a more you know really a
general understanding in some sense of
those that concept
but to Casey your point I think having a
static Benchmark is is a problem
sort of putting out a benchmark
that everybody can kind of
try and optimize their program to solve
we've seen that over and over again
that ends up being um
sort of a a way that people end up
reverse engineering to a particular task
rather than to a more General set of
conceptual understanding so I do think
that you have to keep changing our
benchmarks we can't just say okay here's
imagenet
go you know
beat on that for the next 20 years until
you've solved it that's not going to
yield uh general intelligence
yeah I think um one of the issues we're
talking about in general is
extrapolation so you know Chalet used
extrapolation to talk about skill
programs and and being able to do things
beyond your prize and experience but
with benchmarks it's about human
extrapolation so I think part of the
problem with the risk debate by the way
why everyone's so suddenly worried about
risk is because of this Benchmark
problem and that's because we see that
humans who can do a can do B and now we
see machines that can do a and and we
have all of these built-in assumptions
in in benchmarks and and we don't really
realize that we're talking about
machines now we're not talking about
computers anymore and I think it's
causing a real problem I I don't want to
be hyperbolic here but it feels like
there's this massive delusion taking
over the entire machine learning
community and we're seriously talking
about AI risk and I I think it all comes
down to these benchmarks fundamentally
yeah I do think all of our benchmarks
have as you say have this problem of um
that they have assumptions built in that
if a human could do this
that then the machine must if the
machine does it it has the same
kind of
um
generalization capacity as a human who
could solve that problem you know this
goes back all the way to say like
the chess as a benchmark
so people used to think that if because
of a human can play Chess at a Grand
Master Level you know that means they
must be super intelligent in other ways
that if a machine could play Chess at
that level
um it would also have be super
intelligent like a human Herbert Simon
even said that explicitly
um but then we saw that chess actually
could be conquered by very unintelligent
Brute Force
uh search that didn't generalize in it
anyway so
I think this is an issue today with
large language models you know they they
can do things like pass the bar exam and
pass other standardized
human tests of of skill or intelligence
but what does that mean
it doesn't necessarily mean the same
thing for a machine as it does for a
human for many different reasons
yeah I guess it's a similar thing with
the mccorduck effect that we have
relative pointers to what we think of as
being intelligence we just point to
something and then when that thing
um becomes easy then we need to kind of
move the pointer
yeah I think it also feeds into as Tim
was saying I think it heightens the fear
of existential risk because of this this
concept that we have of intelligence
always wins which even among humans is
is a flawed concept right I mean you
know many Nerds who grew up through
Elementary School can tell you like
intelligence doesn't always win right
like sometimes it's numbers or brute
force or whatever else kind of kind of
wins and they assume like well if we
were to have this purified intelligence
that was super intelligence it would be
as if a human brain were super
intelligent and they'd be able to do
everything a human being could do and
hurt other people and conquer the world
and fight Wars and and that again is
this anthropomorphic projection right
yeah I mean
right so and it's this notion that
intelligence is this thing that you can
just have more and more of
forever forever or so far that it's just
beyond any you know it's almost magical
right and it's capable right and it's
not you know a different view of
intelligence is that it's a collection
of adaptations to specific problems for
a particular kind of uh organism in an
environment
and it's not the sort of a
an open-ended pure
domain independent thing
so I think this is why you know you see
a lot of discussion of super
intelligence AGI
you know AI risk in in among
computer scientists but you don't see a
lot of it discussed among like
psychologists or
animal intelligence people or other
cognitive scientists
because that's not the way that they
understand intelligence
I would love to explore more about that
because
um I mean only yesterday when we were
talking about an activism we're also
talking about um Gibson's ecological
psychology and even Elizabeth spelkey I
mean this kind of cognitive psychology
view is very related to nativism it's
this idea that we have these fundamental
cognitive Primitives and intelligence in
some senses just traversing or
recomposing this library of cognitive
modules that we have and and those
modules are very physically situated you
know they they tell you something about
the environment that you're in
um which means that intelligence is just
very gnarly and it's very kind of
coupled to the environment we're in it
can't really be magically abstracted in
a computer with infinite scale
yeah I think that's that's right that
that's you know people have different
views about the nativism
uh empiricism debate
and there's whole different schools and
cognitive science about like how how
much is learned how much is
evolutionarily built in and all of that
but I think most people in the field
would agree with what you said that
intelligence is very uh gnarly
it's it is situated it is
specific to particular domains of our
concern to a particular organism and
that it's not easily abstractable you
know that back in the early days of AI
we had um
Noel and Simon
two of the pioneers of of AI who have
this thing called the physical symbol
system hypothesis which was that
basically you could sift off
intelligence from any material substrate
like the brain and put it in some other
materials substrate like a computer they
were thinking about symbols
um but nowadays people have the same
kind of view
um with uh neural net sir uh
Transformers or whatever that you can
take human intelligence that's very
situated and
tied to the environment and sort of sift
off the pure part and leave all of that
bodily stuff and you can get something
like super intelligent so I don't think
in most people in cognitive science
would agree with that
well on the other hand though I think
and I'd be curious to get your take on
this is uh One Direction that that comes
from is for those of us and I include
myself in this Camp tentatively you know
that at the end of the day what the
brain does is some form of computation
you know like absence the proof that
there's such a thing as hyper
computation like our brain all of its
calculations could be you know embodied
in a large enough you know turing
machine and a large enough computer of
some kind and therefore everything that
we do including our our intelligent
activities
um could be coded somehow or another
into a turing equivalent system and for
the record I don't believe neural
networks are I've said this like
multiple times at least in their current
manifestations they're not they're just
a feed forward you know thing at the end
of the day but if you actually had a
computer you could have human symbolic
intelligence encoded like where do you
stand on that
on that debate if you will
yeah I I I have nothing against the idea
that the brain does computations
I I think that's
that's you know one possible way to look
at it
um and that
those kinds of computations could be
implemented in another kind of computer
but the brain is a very special kind of
sort of biological computer that's been
evolved to do specific things and one of
the main things the brain has been
evolved to do is control the body
and in particular kinds of environments
and so I think the brain is doing
computations but it's doing very very
highly evolved
very domain uh specific computations
that um okay
perhaps
don't necessarily make sense without
having a body
now that's debatable
but it does seem like a lot of the way
that we
uh reason is by reference to our own
um
sort of episodic experience in the world
or at least to the capabilities that
have been built into us you know in like
visual using our visual cortex to
imagine cubes and spheres and whatever
else we need to solve a physics problem
or a geometric sure sure
yeah so I I'm fine with saying the brain
is a computer of a certain kind but
that's not to say that
um it's going to be uh
you can just kind of lift off the
computations uh
and and and and then put them in a
different substrate and kind of get
everything that's human-like because I'm
not sure that that those computations
are going to make sense in the absence
of the rest of the the organism
yeah there was something that always
confused me about the auto poetic
inactivists because of course they as
and they assure representationalism and
information processing but they also
issue computationalism in general and as
Keith was just saying I don't even if
cognition is externalized I don't see
any reason why in principle you couldn't
just compute the entire system and and
recreate the computation I just wanted
to close the loop on on the arc
challenge stuff though so you said that
the winning solutions to um Francois
Challenge on kaggle they were quite
simplistic in a way they were like a
genetic search over lots of primitive
kind of functions and even the winner
said that they didn't feel it was a
satisfying solution which was
interesting and and then you tried it on
gpt4 and I think you said you got around
30 there's now a deep mind paper app
very recently which just uh basically
turned it all into a character set with
a random mapping put it into gpt4 I
think got nearly 60 even even somewhat
invariant to the translation between the
character set mapping some focus on our
Discord Forum tried to reproduce it and
couldn't that's the problem with gbt4
you can never reproduce anything
um but um I was just wondering would you
consider that To Be An Elegant solution
it's not really much better than
searching over a DSL is it by that you
mean giving it to gpt4
well I mean it's quite an interesting
thing isn't it that if if we there's the
mccorduck effect and even before you get
to a solution what would a good AI
solution look like I mean what would
someone have to create for you to say oh
that's a really cool AI solution
well if if you had a program that really
could
solve
this these tasks in a general way that
would whatever however it worked it
would be a good AI solution you know I
don't necessarily think we have to have
uh something like the way people do it
well let me let me see if I can guess
though maybe an extension of what you
said is is uh and it's it's in line with
your argument that the benchmarks have
to evolve is I think that these
benchmarks really is just first pass or
low pass filters it's like they weed out
the junk it's like well if you can't
pass the art challenge I'm not going to
bother with you if you pass the art
challenge now we have to look further
right which is like okay so it's been
able to generalize along these you know
19 Concepts that we've defined and and
concept art with little pixel grids what
about if we give it like full frame you
know pictures or video or something is
it able to to generalize there no okay
it failed why did it fail well now we
need to do some more engineering like
it's going to be this kind of
never-ending sort of iterative process
so I would say if something passes Arc
or concept Arc then it's worthy of
further study
sure yeah I agree I mean you know one
question is that arc's a very you know
idealized kind of microworld type domain
so right does It capture
what's interesting about the real world
in terms of abstraction
I you know to to some extent yes
probably and to some extent probably no
so you're right that doesn't solving Arc
doesn't mean we're we're at AGI
it's like in chess which you brought up
earlier you know
if you took if you took uh whatever the
current best let's say lc0 or something
like that and it's been trained on
standard chess and then you have a go
play chess 960 formerly called Fisher
random where you just random it's just
gonna suck like humans are gonna destroy
it right because
humans have learned a more generalized
and and by the way that also destroys
human beings who rely on memory and just
sort of like the the memorized positions
that haven't learned let's say the skill
of playing chess right and so this is
the type of thing that's going to happen
right it's like you say when you take
this intelligence and try to apply it to
a different context that's when the
rubber meets the road as to whether or
not you really learned the concepts
right yeah no definitely I agree and I I
don't think like our concept Arc wasn't
meant to be like a test of AGI in any
sense it was meant to be kind of a
stepping stone to getting to
abilities for abstraction and clearly if
some program was able to solve all of
the problems in that domain and
we'd have to then test it further uh you
know we'd have to have it be able to
extrapolate to a new kind of domain that
tested the same kinds of Concepts
so you're right there's no end in some
sense
um but at some point I guess and I don't
know when that point is we have to say
well this thing you know seems to be
understanding this concept
uh yeah that's the wonderful Continuum
though because you said earlier there's
something deeply unsatisfying about
Chess brute forcing everything and when
we apply Francois measure of
intelligence we don't think of that as
intelligent because it's just Brute
Force experience and then we find
something which is a little bit more
efficient so it's something which
appears to work but now this another
interesting thing is when you talk about
Concepts you had this beautiful logical
article out earlier this year talking
about on top of she's on top of the
world and what would Dolly draw it would
draw a globe with with a with a you know
someone dancing on top of it or I'm on
the TV you know what what does that mean
it should mean that I'm actually being
rendered on on the TV now um it's kind
of like what we were saying with goals
isn't it because this skill program
someone just goes on kaggle and they
gives you this program and it seems to
work but it's horribly complicated and
how do you know that the internal
representations are in any way related
to these other abstractions and and do
you think that the abstractions as well
are somehow Universal in the same way
spellkey would say that the cognitive
prize are yeah I think it's
it's something we can't see and we don't
you know we don't know with humans
and we don't know with machines because
both of both of these are very complex
systems that are hard to kind of pull
apart what are the internal
representations uh so
in in most cases we have to rely on
Behavior which is very
noisy I think that's you know it can be
it can be misleading and you know it
turns out that humans
often are not
you know if you give them
a a a problem like a reasoning problem
in in a familiar domain they're much
better at doing that problem as doing
the exact same reasoning kind of
abstract reasoning task in an unfamiliar
domain
and I think that's something that is
people have shown is also true of of
large language models because they've
learned from Human
uh language and have Incorporated sort
of the statistics of some of the
statistics of Human Experience
um that they're much better on familiar
domains than on non-familo domains but
the one thing that humans can do is
often they can kind of transcend that
and learn how to reason much more
abstractly
uh which I don't know if we will get to
that point with language models yet
so there's there's a wonderful paper
that just came out um
from um
a group at MIT and some other places
called
um
I I can't remember exactly what it's
called it was uh
something like reasoning versus reciting
and and what they they do is they talk
about this notion of a counter factual
task
which is if you can do one task like
addition and base 10 and you really
understand that notion of addition you
should be able to do addition and base
eight
and so but you haven't had as much
experience as like for a language model
it's not
almost all of the training data is has
to do with base 10.
so but can so they tested they did a
whole bunch of these so-called
counterfactual tasks with and showed
that gpt4 is really good at the original
task but not so good at the counter
factual task
so it's not in some sense it is relying
on sort of patterns in its training data
rather than
genuine abstraction
it's a stochastic parrot right well you
know it could be argued that humans do
that a lot too sure uh I don't know if
you call it a stochastic parrot but it's
more like a pattern matcher
and it's not
it's not reasoning about the things in
the sense that we think of reasoning you
know as sort of uh domain independent
ability uh it's very domain dependent
um
yeah so the difference is that I guess
the difference I would say is that
humans
it
can
kind of overcome that domain dependency
in some cases and actually get to the
true abstraction but uh I don't know
that language models can
yeah I mean there's a couple of things
here so um first of all these language
models fail at things which
four-year-old children can do and
um they can pass the bar exam but as
you've said previously you wouldn't want
one of these things to actually go and
practice my God could you could you
imagine the thought and um there was
this Sparks of AGI paper where they gave
this I mean maybe you could recite this
better than me but there is the thing
about the the book nine eggs a laptop a
bottle and a nail can you balance it in
a stable Manner and this comes back to
the experiment design because my God in
any other discipline of science they
would just tear this apart they would
say well that's not very robust I mean
you came up with an example uh with a
with a pudding a marshmallow a toothpick
um you know how would it balance it yeah
yeah did it not balance the full glass
of water on top of the marshmallow I
mean this is just stuck into the
marshmallow and then you know yeah
that's not exactly what we had in mind
no and in fact the Sparks of AGI paper
they explicitly said
um we're doing anthropology not not
cognitive science you know well that's
not the way it was interviewed
unfortunately there are YouTube channels
now dedicated to educating people on AI
and they're taking this as gospel I mean
yeah what's going on
I think there there's just not as much
of a
focus on sort of scientific method in
this field as there should be
and
I think you know in science
if you're you know you're looking at a
phenomenon you're trying to replicate it
if it replicates if it only replicates
half the time that's not a replication
that's not a robust replication whereas
for language models people are saying
well if it can do this task once
in one particular uh circumstances then
it probably has this more General
capability so if it can do this stacking
problem once
then wow it has physical common sense
um
and you know people with my marshmallow
example people of course jumped on it
said wait if you prompt it in a certain
way and you you know you do all this
prompt engineering human engineering it
does it right engineering and then like
well that's not the point the point is
not any particular example the point is
figuring out how to test things so that
they that you actually have some kind of
robust stability for replicating a
capability
which we haven't seen with with
experiments on language models very much
I mean people are starting to do this
people are starting to do this kind of
more scientifically grounded
experimental method on language models
but it's still not not very there's not
very much of it
so you might appreciate a phrase a
recently coined because it covers this
leakage too of like sort of leakage of
human knowledge which is if you can't
find the priors look in the mirror right
it's like we have to learn how to do
experimental science and computer
science and you've got to guard against
this type of you know leakage really and
human human engineering and over
involvement right whatever and this is
why I I really want to collaborate with
you know people in developmental
psychology with people in like animal
cognition who face this kind of issue
all the time and you know one example
was
um
from I got from a developmental
psychologist was that like
sometimes like a three-year-old
can tell you
something like
you know four plus three is seven
but if you say if you give them a bunch
of marbles and say pick out four of them
they can't do it
so there you say okay that this this kid
doesn't understand the concept of four
they're kind of just reciting something
that they've heard
um and this is the kind of experiments
that people in developmental psychology
psychology do all the time
to really tease out what these system
what what babies and children know and
what they can do and it's not an easy
thing to do and you know this whole this
kind of experiment
the problem with that is it's extremely
complex and requires so much domain
knowledge so it takes a very long time
because I think there is another article
um uh that that spoke about how we study
rats and we you know those folks in
different disciplines they're they're
really really good experimental design
and and they have experts who kind of
create very very clear criteria for for
measuring this behavior and with AI um
you know everything's going up on on
archive and everything's going at a
million miles an hour and by the time
you actually design a systematic
rigorous study for the first thing
there's already another paper coming out
which is claiming to do it differently
so we just can't keep up it's just it's
an absolute nightmare absolutely
yeah agreed
I wanted to so I'll quickly touch on one
more thing and I know Keith wants to go
into complexity but um yeah so the
information leakage is a problem the
brittleness is a problem I do think of
these GPT models a bit like a database
and so anything that requires physical
grounding of course doesn't work very
well some things work surprisingly well
like you know programming because
programming is mostly in the internet it
still has all sorts of failure modes and
it's not very reliable but it's
surprisingly reliable
um but um you you put a paper out with
Tannenbaum and a whole bunch of other
people and and and you actually said
well if you want some policy advice if
you really want to think about how we
can improve this situation you said
aggregating benchmarks and also giving
instance level failure modes can
actually help us understand why things
went wrong or you know why things gave
us the right answer for the wrong
reasons and um there are all sorts of
limiting factors you said you know we
have this kind of censorship by
concision you're only allowed to have
seven pages in your conference Workshop
paper and there's no policy about this
so can can you give us a heads up on
that
yeah I mean you know traditionally in
machine learning people use accuracy and
similar kinds of uh aggregate measures
to report their results
and you know if someone tells you that
the accuracy was you know 78 percent
what does that tell you exactly how I
think you know this gets back to the
idea of scientific method you know it in
science the most interesting things are
the failures
and those are the things you really have
to focus on it's like why did it fail
and that's what we need to know to
understand machine Learning Systems so
the most simple
kind of reporting would be just to
report for every instance in your
Benchmark your data set
how did the system do what did what was
its answer uh and and that's not you
know it doesn't seem like a very uh big
ask
but it would be very useful
and
that we now have in conferences you're
allowed to have some kind of
supplementary material online so you
could do have this available and we did
we did this for our concept Arc paper we
showed for every instance like what what
humans did What machines did we tried to
analyze the errors of the system and I
think this these kinds of reporting will
be will give us a lot more insight into
what these systems are doing and what
they're like real capabilities are
yeah and and it's and back to the
difficulty that Tim mentioned earlier I
totally agree and this is work that has
to be done like if if we are going to
build a science of machine cognition you
know this work has to be done yeah I
think um and I just want to shout out to
Ryan uh Burnell who who spearheaded that
paper because he really is it's the one
pushing for all this and I think it's
fantastic
yeah so just in the in the last few
minutes you know since since we have you
uh complexity and complexity theory is
is a topic I really love I'm not an
expert in it at all but I like to think
about I like to explore it I'm just
curious you know from your perspective
on what are some of the most interesting
things happening right now in complexity
Theory and if I wanted to go learn a bit
more and check out just some cool you
know latest stuff which what should we
go look at
so I think there's you know there's a
lot of interesting stuff going on
obviously and and complex systems is a
huge umbrella for a lot of research but
if you're interested in it the one big
uh topic that people look at is called
scaling
and it's the question of like what
happens to a system as it gets bigger in
some sense so this started out with some
work on um the the sort of uh energy use
of systems like animals essay as their
Maps increases and people discovered
some really interesting scaling laws
that were very non-intuitive and they
were able to explain these laws using
ideas like fractal fractals and the
fractal structure of complex systems
um but now so this is all unlike
biological metabolism and things like
that
but now a lot of people are extending
that scaling work to to um
cities so asking what happens to cities
when they increase in size either in
area or in population size and
there's all kinds of phenomena that you
can see like what's the rate of
innovation measured by something like
patents oh fascinating and what's the
rate of uh sort of energy usage by a
city
um and what's how do these things change
even like the happiness of the people
you know are people in New York happier
than people in Santa Fe which is a much
smaller City uh
these things scale in really interesting
ways and it's opening up a lot of new
ideas about how social systems work
and how it's similar thing that you
can't trust the benchmarks because how
happy people are might you look at the
rate of antidepressant usage or
something yeah so you do have all these
right I don't know if that's exactly
what they use but um you do have to look
at ways to measure these things which
can be questioned
uh yeah but there are a lot of really
and I think this whole science the
science of cities is it's very
preliminary and there's a lot of ideas
about how to measure these things how to
uh develop sort of analytical
descriptions or laws that govern certain
properties and how to interpret them but
there's just a lot of really interesting
work in this and and
it turns out that now that everybody has
a cell phone
you can really do a lot of tracking
of a lot of these quantities can be
tracked by people's sort of their
movement their interaction with other
people and all these things that
you know have you can measure using uh
cell phones so that's very cool
that is yeah thank you that sounds
actually fascinating and and one reason
why for me particularly is are you
familiar with um asimov's Foundation
series yeah so you know psycho history
in there was this the science and it was
like almost like a thermodynamics of
human behavior that was only applicable
at kind of planet scale and Beyond so
it's like these scaling laws so this is
yes
one step towards psycho history exactly
of asimov's kind exactly yeah
cool and then closing does does that
give you intuition on the scaling of
intelligence
[Laughter]
that's a great question and um I think
you know one question you can ask is
like there's individual intelligence and
then there's collective intelligence
hmm and how much of the intelligence
that we have individually is actually
grounded in a more collective
intelligence you know I there's many
things that I don't know like I don't
understand quantum mechanics or
something but I know somebody who does
and therefore I feel like it's
understood
I said
and a lot of our intelligence I think is
sort of more social than we think
oh absolutely and um folks should
definitely read Melanie's book so uh
your complexity book we actually covered
that quite a lot on our show on on
emergence it's absolutely wonderful and
of course your book on on AI
um is probably the best book on on AI
I've ever read it's up there with um
Christopher Summerfield's book but
anyway um Melanie it's honestly you are
my hero thank you so much for coming on
mlst I really appreciate it thanks so
much for having me I really enjoyed it
it's great talking to you